welcome back to new rockers I'm your
buddy Sam today I'm gonna be talking
about one of my favorite episodes of the
flash to date episode 404 elongated
journey in tonight's point out all those
Easter Egg missable details you know it
let's talk about it but here's your
spoiler warning for the episode the
flash here is the comics basically
everything oh I do so love a top 10 list
so kick it off with number 10 breacher
movies so cool
readers played by Danny Trejo of course
who hild it by the way machete Jews
preacher is a relatively new character
created for the JLA vibe solo series for
the new 52 back in 2013 and there's
nothing really to know about him besides
that guess he can breach realities just
like vibe and yes he is gypsies father
and yes gypsies real name is Cynthia but
Reacher his real name is well mortars
more death your choice really and
normally he wears this giant metal suit
not the leather jacket number he does in
this episode but I'd loved it anyway
speaking of which notice what preacher
destroys the minute that he arrives on
earth one that's right the matrix poster
I just think this is like a fun job at
preachers TV costume which looks like it
was inspired from the u.s. jacket and
the matrix I gotta be honest I hope we
see preacher many more times in this
season because he's amazing he's just
delightful so terrifying speaking about
coming back to the show let's talk about
Mayor Anthony bellows everybody's
favorite recurring character yay we've
seen this charming civil servant
actually a couple times on the flash TV
series but listen to this line right
here before I was mayor I was a cop in
this very precinct ding ding ding this
is a hardcore fan Easter Egg for people
who have watched the flash in any form
of media this confirms that Mayor
Anthony Bell is he used to be officer
Tony bellows from the original flash TV
show from the 90s that starred John
Wesley Shipp who is now played Henry
Allen and now Jay Garrick on the new
flash so not only has the CW pulled Mark
Hamill's trickster over from that show
to the current one but also tony bellows
lives on as the crooked mayor of central
city keep those hoorays coming for a
reference that should make all of the
internet happy when Henry gives Cisco
the advice to take Reacher to coffee
that little whining says have fun
storming the castle mmm-hmm Princess
Bride fans better be blowing up the
comments down below in celebration for
those of you who have not seen the
Princess Bride it's got hundreds of
quotes that fans love to use all the
time and have fun storming the castle
here's one of the biggies since Tom
Cavanagh directed this episode I kind of
hope that
this was his suggestion like here's a
little Adler because he's great moving
on to the main plot of this episode were
introduced to a new character that we've
been begging for years for to hop onto
this show Ralph give me is here and he's
a jerk but we love him but he's rude to
everybody but I just can't get enough
now I've mentioned before that Harrison
wells in season 1 said that he is a
person that died during the particle
accelerator explosion I heard a lot of
people that night people you don't even
know their names
Jake Davenport Daria Kim Ralph did man
and I was hoping for a proper
explanation in this episode as to why
he's still alive but and that didn't
happen however the showrunners work
question about this and they did give a
reason as to why he's still alive and
it's a fine answer Andrew Kreisberg
stated flashpoint erased that don't
matter changed it sorry exactly it's
obviously a joke but that's a half
answer and my nerd heart's a little mad
I do want to point out a fun Easter egg
here where Ralph is speaking with a
woman about our husband's whereabouts
listen closely to that last name he said
your husband didn't die in that plane
crash mrs. Broome there it is fun not to
the creator of Ralph de bak the
elongated man John wroom wroom created
elongated man back when he was writing
the flash comic in 1960 and also fun
fact he created Kid Flash thanks Broome
speaking of other fun comic book greater
references check out the name of Ralph's
neighbor's office J Chung and r Lang and
I believe J Chun is actually a reference
to a popular artist for both DC and
Marvel she's worked on Batman Gotham
Knights Swamp Thing and the Multiversity
guidebook which is funny because
breacher invited me can we do the
multiverse get it wink wink now I
couldn't find anything on are laying
besides the possible fund nod to Lana
Lang let me know what you found in the
comments down below
moving on to more fun references let's
take a look at the scene with Reacher
and Cisco at jitters now listen to all
the names that breach her list i abided
some of the worst breach criminals in
history
Marla the Dark Lord Salonga
Udrih the sandpeople of scar you will be
easy prey while they all sound like very
sci-fi and comic book II names they
aren't actually BC characters as far as
I could tell from my research except for
one Marla the Dark Lord
pretty spooky I believe this is actually
a nod to more do the Dark Lord who's a
fairly popular villain in BC comics
originally appearing in the Superman
comics way back when the Dark Lord has
been a thorn in the side of many DC
characters and teams including the
Justice Society of America who is
showing up in the DC TV world and the
Legion of super-heroes who will soon be
in the Supergirl universe very exciting
the Dark Lord is a pretty powerful foe
so you know breacher doesn't mess around
if he was able to take him down and it
also be kind of cool to see him pop up
on the flash because I want to see Barry
go up against some magic enemies what'd
you guys think pretty cool right next up
on the list notice the beverage iris
finds in Roth's desk when her and Barry
are looking for a DNA and Rob's
office bing-bang-boom that's a big
Easter Egg for the elongated Man fans
there weren't a lot before and now
there's a bunch Gingold oh so cool now
in the comics Ralph isn't a medic he
actually uses a special serum called
Gingold which is the juice of the gingko
fruit of course when he drinks it it
allows them to become extremely elastic
uh-huh now it doesn't last forever and
it can be dangerous for other people
that drink it but for Ralph it allows
him to you know save lives be a hero the
whole shebang I'm kind of glad that he's
a normal meta in this show but we also
got again gold reference what do you
guys think would you prefer it be a
serum let me know in the comments down
below
moving on when cisco was prepping to set
a trap for breacher notice what he grabs
and then sets aside hmm I believe this
be a fun little nod to the overload top
fantastic machete films number 3 in the
list you know they start Danny Trejo and
he's this ultimate badass who just kills
a bunch of guys if you guys have not
seen them and you need a kick-ass movie
to watch this evening I highly recommend
both of those films we also get a nod to
another Trejo film right here see maybe
the predator
but I'm the shorts if you guys missed
predators the most recent installment to
the predator franchise Danny Trejo
actually plays a small role in there as
well top the original with Arnold
Schwarzenegger but I'm still cool not
now on just some more Danny Trejo
goodies when breacher is holding down
Cisco in STAR Labs makes a few
references that I just wanted to point
out really quick for our number two slot
Watchmen reach your walks into Cisco's
trap what the shield CEO is actually a
type of hell or dark place that the Dead
go to that originated from the Hebrew
faith Magnus is just a kind of fun nod
to the multiverse in general how we say
things differently then listen to where
breacher got his super cool blade I pull
this from the body of an earth 4,800
kilmer you can't trap a trap now as far
as I can tell the hunter killers are
from a popular comic series of the same
name
not from DC but earth 48 is the home to
some of the most formidable protectors
in the multiverse called the forerunners
there are some of the main fighters that
go up against dark science you know they
don't mess around well we see any of
them on the show highly doubtful but
cool they got a nod now speaking of not
messing around whoever is after Caitlin
means business who could it be
well we get a pretty good hint in the
first episode and then again in this
episode with this scene our number 1
slot that horseshoe on the ground is
awfully suspicious I'm getting the
feeling that this could be a hint that
Caitlin's soon going to have to go up
against m-net I mean that seems to want
killer frost back in her pack of rogues
ice puns and all I'm thinking since
Almanac can control metal this might
just be a little reminder that Caitlin
can't go back to her old life just yet
and since the next week's episode Girls
Night Out has been hinted you the team
facing off against Alma net I'm thinking
we're about to get some cool fight
scenes with the metal wielding badass
villain but what do you guys think is
this horse shoe for AMA net or is it for
another classic horse themed villain and
find Annie but let me know in the
comments down below here are a few
honorable mentions just to be safe the
title elongated journey in tonight for
the episode isn't not too long day's
journey and tonight a popular play by
Eugene O'Neill Cisco's t-shirt is a fun
redundancy because the octothorpe is the
actual name for the hashtag symbol fun
the chemical sulfur zinc oxide and
stearic acid the compounds that Caitlin
gives Ralph to help put himself back
together are actually the main
ingredients to make rubber so probably
shouldn't be drinking that Ralph but hey
but it is poison and finally the nose
wiggle we got during the final shot of
this episode is a nod to Ralph's nose
wiggle in the comics supposedly he can
literally smell out a mystery or crime
in the air but you know some characters
have doubted in the comics hayley green
arrow and me too because I don't
understand how that works but hey it's
comics and that's it kids let me know
what you thought of this episode and
what theories you have for the rest of
the season in the comments down below
make sure you like this video and check
out all of our other reviews and
breakdowns on the new rock star Channel
we're putting out some awesome stranger
things content that I know you all enjoy
hit me up on Twitter at Sam bash if you
have any more questions or if you just
want to chat again I'm Sam and I'll see
you next time